build a business around what you're
passionate about or you will fail you
have to love what you do you have to
love what you do so much and gets you so
excited that you can't wait to wake up
and go and do it again otherwise you're
going to quit starting the business is
one of the most frustrating challenging
time-consuming things you're ever going
to do in your life people will tell you
you're crazy that you're stupid that
you're wasting your time they're going
to reject you and say no and you're
going to doubt yourself countless times
the only thing that's going to get you
through is that passion for what you're
doing you should want to do what you're
doing even if you weren't getting paid
for it that's the test if your only
reason for starting to businesses to try
to make money then you're going to fail
one hundred percent Steve Jobs
co-founder of Apple when he was in
college he decided to drop out after one
semester so he could drop in on a
computer hobbyist club people thought he
was crazy why would you drop out of
college to go hang out with bunch of
geeks we're trying to build personal
computers who's going to need a personal
computer anyway what a stupid idea and
even though it didn't quite make sense
to him at the time he still did it
because he had to follow his passion he
then decided to sell his car to raise
the thirteen hundred dollars that they
needed to launch a little company called
apple and again people thought he was
crazy you dropped out of college you
sold your car to do this computer thing
it's such a stupid idea why would you do
this nobody's ever going to need one and
again even though it didn't quite make
sense he had to do it because he was
passionate about and he had to follow it
by the time was 23 seed Jobs worth a
million dollars I was 24 is with ten
million dollars that was 25 was worth a
hundred billion dollars that's what he
got for following his passion but he
didn't quit there because it was never
about the money for Steve Jobs he loved
what he did and he wanted to put a dent
in the universe so he kept going was
never about the money if you just
starting a business make sure I urge you
from the bottom of my heart make sure
that you're doing it
around something that you love doing and
is helping people if you're just doing
it to make money you're going to fail
you have to do something that gets you
excited helps people and that you love
doing so much that it's going to push
you through all those dark days it's
going to be tough but I promise you
there's light on the other end of the
tunnel the dots may not connect now but
they will somewhere in your future if
you follow your bash good luck